smart motorways are due to be axed after
the Prime Minister Rishi sunak admitted
the public has lost confidence in the
concept well this all follows years of
campaigning from families of Crash
victims live to our political
correspondent Ali Fortescue in
Westminster so highly controversial for
many years and there we have it
yes that's right there's been pressure
on the government on this and this was
something that Rishi sunak said he
wanted to do in the conservative
leadership campaign we're saying about
10 of England's motorways are made up of
smart motorways obviously this was a
kind of long term experiment in a sense
and as we know the way it works is that
one lane of traffic
um can be instead of being used as a
hard shoulder can be used for vehicles
but obviously there were as we know
plenty of safety concerns because if you
don't have a hard shoulder where do cars
a broken down go
um the theory was that because they're
smart they would change and that the
lane would be closed down if a car broke
down but it smart motorways as you know
have been linked to fatalities so now
the Prime Minister has confirmed that
they will no longer be built in the UK
and 14 planned smart motorways that were
due to be given the go-ahead are being
acts they were paused last year's data
was collected to work out how safe they
are but now we know that these stretches
that are reportedly on parts of the M1
M6 M25
um costing the taxpayer it's estimated
about a billion pounds are being asked
the government say this is in part down
to money but also down to safety as I
say something which you see anak spoke
about in his leadership campaign it has
come to the Delight of safety
campaigners but already as reported in
the telegraph the AAA and the RAC bosses
are asking the government to go further
and ban the existing smart motorways so
I'm sure that this debate and discussion
will carry on but for now the
government's saying no new smart
motorways are going to be built and
they're going to be axing
um 14 smart midways that had been
planned